four seasons as we all know is a lovely
hotel and the reason it's a lovely hotel
is not because of the fancy beds any
hotel can buy a fancy bed
it's because the people who work there
that when you roam the halls
and somebody says hello to you uh you
get this distinct feeling that they
wanted to say hello not that they were
told to say hello you know we're
we're highly attuned social animals we
can we can tell the difference
anyway they happen to have a coffee bar
in the lobby of the four seasons in las
vegas and so one afternoon i went and
bought myself a cup of coffee
and there happened to be a barista
working that day named noah
noah was funny and engaging and charming
and i stood there for far too long
buying my cup of coffee because i just
so enjoyed talking to noah
so as is my nature i asked noah do you
like your
job and without skipping a beat noah
says i love my job
so immediately my ears perk up because
in my line of work
like and love are very different like is
rational i like the people i work with i
get paid well i like the challenge i
like my job love is emotional it's a
higher order connection
like do you love your wife i like her a
lot right
it's it's different right it's very
different uh
noah said i love my job so i'm
interested this kid has an emotional
connection
to being a barista at a fancy hotel
right
so immediately i followed up and said
tell me specifically what the four
seasons is doing
that you would say to me you love your
job and without skipping a beat noah
said throughout the day
managers will walk past me and ask me if
there's anything that i need
anything that they can do to help me do
my job better not just my manager any
manager
he said and then he said i also work at
another hotel
and there the managers walk past us and
catch us if we're doing things wrong
there they just drive performance
there i like to keep my head below the
radar just get through the day
and collect my paycheck only at the four
seasons do
i feel i can be myself now think about
that for the for just a second this is
the exact same human being
whose performance attitude and customer
face
customer service will be profoundly
different
not because of him but because of the
leadership environment in which he's
working and
so often we blame the people and we
don't look at the people who are leading
the people
or the environment in which we're asking
them to work this is the same
person it's one of the most frequent
questions i get when i talk to business
leaders
how do i get the most out of my people
it's a flawed question people are not a
towel
like a wet towel that you ring them out
and see how much you can get out of them
it's a flawed question which means
you're going to get flawed answers
the correct question is how do i create
an environment in which my people can
work
at their natural best and that's an
entirely different skill set